okay so report came out deep mistrust
has developed between white house and
zelinski this is a hotter story an
ominous detail is very buried in Tom
Friedman's column this is a guy who had
lunch at the White House with Biden less
than three months ago the timing of
Pelosi's visit could not be worse dear
reader the Ukraine war is not over and
privately U.S officials are a lot more
concerned about Ukraine's leadership
than they are letting on there is deep
mistrust between the White House and
president zielinski of Ukraine
considerably more than has been reported
on and there's a funny business there's
funny business going on in Kiev on July
17 zielinski fired his country's
prosecutor General and the leader of its
domestic intelligence agency the most
significant shake-up in his government
since the Russian invasion in February
it would be the equivalent of Biden
firing Merrick Garland and Bill Burns on
the same day
but I have still not seen any reporting
that convincingly explains what was that
all about it is as if we don't want to
look too closely under the hood in Kiev
for fear of what corruption or Antics
might we might see when we have invested
so much there boy that's a very well
written article by the way that make
makes you makes you think about what's
really going on over there Tyler I'll go
to you first what do you think is going
on with this
I think that the White House is exactly
what it says they're terrified to see
that Ukraine is exceptionally corrupt
that it's never been a true democracy
that it's always been an oligarchy and
it's always been exceptionally corrupt
it was what the third most corrupt
country in the world like they rank
these things and it's it's always been
hugely corruptive we've now sent them
what 51 billion dollars 52 billion
dollars and they know they [ __ ] up
they don't want to look they're afraid
of it but then Ben Stiller says
zelinsky's his hero you flew out there
and said yeah you two did the concert in
the subway this thing's been so weird
zelenski's had Russian uh assassins
after him since the war started but he
can do his his shoot with Vogue you've
got people going to the beach it's I
mean it's it's weird man it's one reason
why I I've been very silent since this
whole thing kicked off because from day
one it's just struck me as weird I I
don't get what's going on and again this
comes back to a point I was making
earlier which is with this situation and
so many others I think oftentimes
will conflate governments with the
people
right so when someone even says I stand
with Ukraine or I support Ukraine what
does that mean or if someone has you
know says they don't like the USA or
they don't like Saudi Arabia or whatever
it is and I think it's always a mistake
to conflate
governments with the people of a country
I think anyone who's traveled knows
these things are very very different and
that the CCP is not representative of
Chinese people in general the US
government absolutely is not in uh you
know
I I think virtually every America I feel
like every American I've met is like a
is better than the top people in the
government and so on like so the notion
that the government and the people are
the same thing is very messy so I think
with this situation it's been confusing
because of course you have all the all
the nonsense on social media but when
someone criticizes or is critical of
zelenski or the Ukrainian government or
says they're corrupt right people
automatically jump oh so you're proprude
and you're pro-russia you don't care
about the Ukrainian people it's like no
you can totally care about the people
who have been killed injured displaced
from their homes Etc you can have
complete compassion for those people but
you can also recognize okay at a
governmental level here there's
something weird going on here you've got
that whole azov Battalion in there and
you've got actual neo-nazis who are
fighting in the war I don't know all the
details but it's messy and I think
people try to really simplify it and
just be like okay either you're
pro-russia or your pro your Pro Ukraine
and it's just like well what does that
even what does that even mean I think
we're so quick to label all right that
Putin's the bad guys so those guys must
be the good guys it's you know it's
there's a lot of gray areas what you're
talking about there's more than meets
the eye everyone wants to label Russia
the bad guy and then Ukraine or the good
guys so zelinski is the face of Ukraine
you know good looking young guy what
have you so he's the good guy but I
think what we're learning is maybe there
it's sort of a lesser of two evils thing
Russia can be the bad guy Putin could be
the bad guy but at the same time
Ukraine zielinski can still be corrupt
like Tyler was talking about yourself
yeah I mean it's it's just not it's not
a black and white thing
exactly and I don't speak on it too much
as well because I'm aware that this
stuff has been going on for for decades
these countries have Decades of of
history and I'm very far you know
there's people who didn't know what
Ukraine meant was
right well you remember when we we had
Oliver Stone here yeah okay you remember
the conversations there with what he was
talking about very different perspective
yes and it's not this perspective you're
gonna hear from mainstream media people
were upset about what he was saying so
look I mean when the when when this
thing but but the whole thing with
timing is what the the writer is making
you think because while this is going on
and what ukrainians to Russia is what
Taiwan is to China the closest
correlation and you go during this time
I don't know it's kind of a you know
it's kind of interesting what's going on
over here I I one thing I've been
thinking about a lot over the last few
months and people have brought this
point up I'm not the only one but
I think on a World level
the USA certainly from a governmental
perspective is looking weak and
incompetent right now
and I think that was massively
exemplified by the people have already
forgotten about the uh Afghanistan pull
out last year I mean oh my gosh that was
a complete catastrophe and I think that
with this you know I don't even want I
don't want to be that guy who's I do
wonder I do Wonder would all of this
have happened under Trump would you
Russia have invaded Ukraine would China
be making the moves as making a I doubt
it it's conjecture I don't know but I
think that the USA I think with Biden's
looking we I mean you've got dudes in in
dresses like in the in the cabinet
you've got diversity highs they're
militaries putting out woke ads and
whatever I think if I were in China or I
were Russia and I was like some general
or so I'd be looking over the us and
being like Okay okay right don't
interrupt your enemy when they're when
they're making a mistake right like it's
just looking soft and weak the USA is
not looking as strong on National stage
as strong and as competent as it did
previously whether it's under Trump or
under Obama or under Bush or so on and I
think that China and Russia are seeing
that and I would assume that's why some
of these moves are being made at this
point because the administration is just
just looking weak I mean the president
can't string sentences together so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]